this is very exciting i'm very excited
as a star wars fan and i'm just a fan of
boba fett like this is super cool you
know tomorrow when we saw
boba fett first appear again in the
mandalorian like fans lost their mind
like we all went nuts and then
again when that logo for the book of
boba fett showed up later on the
internet basically exploded but what i
want to know is like when did you know
that it was going to be more than just a
cameo from boba fett and how did it
happen
well i
think uh
well with the mandalorian was sort of
making its way through the galaxy and uh
there were rumors that they were going
to uh
um
want to start with a meeting with john
pepper and dave fallonian john actually
outlined the plan and
and of course i was occurred wow wow and
seeing the concept drawings on the wall
and knowing oh that guy man i'm coming
back this is cool wait cool so yes it
was very very exciting and
john i must say you know he's a man of
his work
he outlined the plan and basically it's
come to fruition
and um just very very blessed and
again the fans liked the re-entry into
the mandalorian
um
and uh i wanted to come in and make a
little bit of a noise bit of a bang and
give them a little bit of energy
and uh very very pleased with the
outcome again just blessed to have
robert rodriguez come in and sort of add
his edge to the whole feel of this book
of bobber and again i think he that's
right he directed that episode that i
returned in the mandalorian as well so
um
so and him being a big boba fett fan
kind of uh yeah it was just one of those
one of those amazing things that um
you know i wouldn't have known it back
in the year 2000 while i was playing
django vet but obviously they sat down
at a meeting and someone said well
papa's going to look like django
well call template of morrison he's down
in new zealand somewhere see what he
looks like get him up here we need a
media
that is a genius yeah yeah and i thank
them yeah you know what's really cool
about what's happening with star wars
now is it's led by people who have been
fans of star wars for such a long time
and may like we know that you're a huge
fan of star wars how do you
keep yourself professional
knowing that you are now like a major
character in this universe like how do
you stop yourself from learning at going
yeah that's me
oh no trust me every time i get on a new
set or in a new environment and i see
something that
gets my nerdgasm going i i am beyond
the biggest nerd on set and uh and
usually that lasts for about five
minutes or so and during rehearsal and
then when we have to buckle down tim is
the one that will
reel me back in and said okay make time
to work
so um
i i think
yes we have to be serious you know
yeah because we have we have way too
much fun and i think what was nice was
that some of that the humor and
everything was you know that that we had
between us
kind of snuck into the relationship
between fennec and boba
because even though they're yeah even
though they're like bounty hunters and
you know assassins
this is a great scene when we're on the
gun ship and we're both
is that is that in the mandalorian no no
um
[Music]
oh it's getting warm in here
on that note you guys know that like
we're super excited for the rest of the
series thank you
yeah thank you